- L'histoire se répète encore
- Arrivés à Québec il y a près
de 10 ans, les Muhibi constatent
avec désolation et inquiétude
la situation de
d'origine, 25 ans après
l'avoir fui.
- On ne peut pas imaginer
comment ils vivent avec cette
situation, spécialement avec les droits des femmes
- Car sous le régime des
talibans, le voile intégral
en public pour les femmes est de nouveau obligatoire alors
que l'école secondaire leur a
été interdite. Ghulshan Muhibi
craint que les talibans ne resserent la vis et
interdisent l'école aussi
pour les plus jeunes filles,
comme c'était le cas pour elle à l'époque
GHULSHAN MUHIBI
- Non, jamais à l'école.
À cause des guerres, à cause des talibans
moi depuis que j'ai grandi, beaucoup de
problèmes dans mon pays.
- Et aujourd'hui,
- C'est la même chose, oui.
- Après 4 ans de démarches,
le couple a pu accueillir
à Québec le cousin de Karim.
Ils espèrent maintenant pouvoir faire venir
leurs cousines, toujours
coincées en Afghanistan,
mais le processus est compliqué.
Aucune réponse de ces gens-là.
- Depuis le début de la crise,
le Canada a accueilli plus de 17 000 réfugiés afghans
sur un objectif de 40 000
en deux ans. 15 d'entre eux
se sont installés à Québec
dans la dernière année.
je ne peux pas croire...
les deux avaient leur visa.
Si le processus est long et ardu, de nouveaux arrivants
peuvent compter le comité
d'accueil aux réfugiés pour
faciliter leur arrivée
- Pendant un an, on est responsables de la famille qui arrive
On les accompagne
dans toutes les démarches
administratives.
- Lucie Trudel et son mari
ont d'ailleurs accueilli Karim et Ghulshan
en septembre 2012. Ils leur ont
trouvé un toit et des biens
essentiels. 10 ans plus tard,
ils sont maintenant citoyens canadiens.
- Parfaitement bien intégrés
c'est une "success-story".
- Quand on est arrivés ici,
tout était prêt pour nous.
- Éternellement reconnaissants, les Muhabis se sont lié d'amitié
avec ceux qui les ont parrainés.
- C'est des gens qui sont
absolument attachants
et pour qui j'ai...
une admiration sans borne.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Arsenault,
Radio-Canada, Beaumont